je vous présente mon épouse la nouvelle
Lady Chatterley nous allons devoir faire
beaucoup de travaux
Oliver Melos croyez-vous que reprendre
un poste de garde chasse pourra vous
apporter entière satisfaction
mais lorsque vous ne voudriez pas nous
donner un coup de main intéressante
n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
il semble bourru de prime aborde
toute cette tendresse
[Musique]
je n'avais pas compris à quel point je
me sentais seul
[Musique]
à votre avis qui s'occupe d'elle pendant
qu'elle s'occupe de vous
elle est épuisée
[Musique]
le mariage le sexe l'amour ce n'est que
du néant
on n'a pas tous la liberté de choisir la
vie qu'on veut
[Musique]
partie de ce monde non plus
je crois que vous comprenez à quel point
cela pourrait mal finir on n'a pas pensé
plus loin que demain
je suis à ridiculiser ma vie
tu es tout pour moi
[Musique]
avec toi je me sens moi-même
je me sens libre
c'est formidable
à quel point peut avoir quelqu'un dans
la peau
qu'y a-t-il d'autre dans la vie
[Musique]